it is great to welcome today dr
bandy x lee to the program who is a yale
university forensic psychiatrist
and uh this is maybe a field dr lee
that not everybody is familiar with can
you talk a little bit about
forensic psychiatry and the work that
you do yes a forensic psychiatrist works
at the interface of psychiatry and the
law
and um so in terms of my clinical work i
mainly work in prisons or state
hospitals where
many legal issues may become important
and we do if evaluations for
courts such as capacity to stand trial
or criminal responsibility
i do civil cases such as asylum cases
and i also have been teaching at
yale law school for 15 years and so
there's a lot of
overlap between the law and psychiatry
so
one of the the general skills and
abilities
seems to be uh evaluating sort of the
uh state the emotional state the
cognitive state
of individuals often in the context of
of criminal proceedings but also in
other contexts as well
yes so you have grown quite a following
on twitter and elsewhere because of some
of the observations you've made about
the president donald trump
and and you know to to make it totally
transparent to the audience
you're very concerned about the behavior
and the actions of the president
um when when did this first become
something you started paying attention
to
and and started to speak out about it
what was it that you were seeing from
the president
you know i was very distant from
any of the political world and was
mainly working as a clinician
and um academic and although i have
consulted with a number of governments
on public policy and
prison reform in particular i had not
considered politics to be a domain for
me to speak about
but the day after donald trump's
presidential election
i was contacted by numerous members from
the public from
civil society members and others who had
known of my work
and so i was inundated with phone calls
and
messages and i
had to think to myself if i have been
working as a violence expert which is
my area within forensic psychiatry and
also
in public health i had been working
to prevent violence at multiple levels
individual collective
societal and would i turn away from the
situation
when it poses perhaps the greatest
level of danger that we could ever face
and potentially be
a trigger for the greatest amount of uh
violence in society
what were the first behaviors of donald
trump's that that made you realize that
there's that possibility of of danger
and violence
well um there are many trigger signs
that we look for in terms of danger and
violence-proneness
and uh and because
past violence is often an indicator for
potential future violence we look at
things like
verbal aggression history of uh boasting
about sexual assaults
and inciting violence as he has done
at his rallies um and
uh definitely during the presidency he
has taunted
allies and enemy nations with nuclear
power
um and all these are signs of danger
of course there are also psychological
characteristics that he exhibited
including impulsivity recklessness uh a
need to
constantly burnish a sense of power uh
preoccupation with a grandiose sense of
self-image uh all of these things are
associated with
violence and therefore things to look
out for so
inevitably and even in the responses
that you sometimes get on twitter
people will bring up the goldwater rule
the goldwater rule you're not supposed
to diagnose you're not supposed to
assign conditions to people
who you have not examined uh in person
and
increasingly i'm reading more and more
about how that was really
a sort of political convention more than
any kind
of um sort of definitive
um uh clinical consideration and that it
dates back to barry goldwater and the
idea that there was an effort uh made
to prevent so-called armchair diagnosis
of what of what were concerns about
about goldwater
before we go further maybe you should
address that in terms of what
what is okay for you to observe and
comment on having not examined
donald trump in person
well first of all the goldwater rule is
unusual
in that it was as you say a political
compromise
it was not it did not derive out of
uh research or clinical concerns or
um professional practice but rather
out of a lawsuit
against a popular newspaper at the time
called fact magazine which had done a
survey of psychiatrists and it was
unusual for the
american psychiatric association to
come up with an ethical so-called
ethical guideline
in response to political situation
but under the trump presidency it has
certainly been abused
it has uh also been modified
about a couple weeks after a couple
months after
donald trump's inauguration uh they
modified it to cover not just diagnosis
but any comment on a public figure of
any kind that actually goes against the
original goldwater rule because the
original goldwater rule was an
affirmative obligation
in that we should participate in
activities that promote public health
and so when we're asked about a public
figure we should
educate the public to improve its health
and well-being
just not diagnose because the diagnosis
you cannot do unless you have all the
medical
records and nowadays we do diagnosis not
by personal interview alone
but by external observation and
getting collateral information from
those who have directly interacted with
the person
so uh so one might say that
the rule has also been invalid since
1980 definitively uh it was considered
in
uh outdated since its inception in 1973
but since 1980 our diagnostic practices
have changed and that we don't
just rely on a personal interview so
that having been clarified i'd love to
get your perspective
on the where or if
sort of some different areas of concern
with the president
overlap or where they are separate so
you've already talked about
the sort of personality traits past
glorification of alleged sexual assault
etc you've kind of outlined that
we then have his assertions about the
cognitive test
he has taken and and claims to have
passed that we believe is the montreal
cognitive assessment which includes
identifying a few animals counting
backwards from 100
by seven uh drawing a clock remembering
words etc there's that piece and i'm
curious
if and how that interacts with your
observations so far
and then there's also these
the the mispronunciation of words
yesterday in fact
repeatedly referring to fatalities as
fatilities and having an expression on
his face that he seems to know he's
saying something wrong but unable to
correct it
the oranges of an investigation is
another example
where there was an expression of
recognition that something was wrong but
unable to say oh no i mean the origins
of an investigation
are these three categories related are
they separate
how do they relate if so
so um i
had been listening to donald trump's
interviews about this recent so-called
recent
cognitive test that he's taken and it
turns out it is the test that he took
over two and a half years ago under
white house
dr ronnie jackson yes and um
and you're correct in that it turns out
to be the montreal cognitive assessment
which really is not it's first of all
not
a fitness exam as dr jackson tried to
assert
it was and also it
uh is not even a good cognitive
screen because research studies have
shown that
full-blown alzheimer patients and
hospitalized schizophrenia patients
can equally ace the test and so
therefore the alzheimer research
consortium
came out stating that the screen should
not replace
a full neuropsychiatric or
neuropsychological examination when it's
indicated
well for the president it certainly is
indicated because he has shown
not only numerous multiple um
very grave signs of
cognitive impairment as well as decline
over time we have considerable
information on him
because of uh multiple public
appearances over time
and it it shows a pattern of decline
that is recognizable for clinicians in
other words
often people become concerned about
joe biden for example but in comparison
uh mr biden's impairments are
superficial and more recognizable
as non-concerning ones whereas mr
trump's
uh impairments are are fit the pattern
a very serious um ongoing
cognitive decline that is related to his
own family history of dementia which he
would be
predisposed to because of his family
history
and now i'm not really making a
diagnosis here because i'd like to point
out that
this can indicate multiple possibilities
of uh cognitive decline for um
for one does not simply come about
because of
uh dementia or other neurogenerative
diseases it can
occur because of stress because of
worsening
um psychiatric conditions
that he uh may otherwise have
or it can be a whole host
of other things so that's why we don't
diagnose without having all the medical
records and without doing
uh a fitting examination even if it
doesn't include a personal interview we
need to do an examination of the data
that are
that are appropriate and so what it
does indicate however is that we are
seeing signs of very
serious pathological processes that need
a
thorough examination not a 10-minute
screen like the montreal cognitive
assessment and
i believe that the president has been
bringing this up himself because he
himself
is concerned about his own mental
fitness he often brings up
topics when he feels that he needs to
fight
um his own notions uh and of course
others as well that he may not be fit
for duty and he has very valid reasons
for concern
but he does this by trying to convince
himself
that he that he is fit and
uh in addition to trying to convince
others and so he
is repeatedly bringing up this test that
he had done two and a half years ago
i think relates to dr ronnie jackson
who was a white house employed um
and as a military officer subordinate to
the commander-in-chief
and so he is he would not be in a
position to do a fitness test
he does not have the independence but he
still used this 10 minute screen to
declare the president
mentally fit in a press conference and
so that in itself is
is a considerable breach of medical
ethics
i don't know whether or not he was aware
of his um false uh
uh declarations but um
because of this episode of
his perhaps administering a test
that really would not tell us very much
but doing so anyhow
uh was perhaps an attempt to reassure
the president
but above all it uh ended up misleading
the public
when um when the public was raising many
questions about the president's fitness
now uh dr jackson has been removed from
his position
about two years ago and amid
other allegations that would make his
medical ethics and standards of practice
questionable
we're going to go to a break on the
podcast tv and radio show but we'll have
our
complete conversation with dr lee on on
our youtube channel
so from a public facing perspective that
any of our viewers and listeners would
be able to just go and look for
themselves
what to you is the most significant
publicly available video or audio
of the president that would that would
raise the flag the highest
in the sense that we've got you know
getting off of air force one and
wandering away
unable to find his vehicle and having to
be brought back we have the word
problems the the speech problems that
we've talked about if you compare an
interview from 10 years ago to one
this year the sort of facility with
diverse vocabulary seems to have been
significantly diminished where there's a
lot of repetition
of of a smaller number of words but
what what is it that anybody would be
able to just say okay this this is what
dr
lee is primarily concerned about in
terms of the evidence
i first of all like to emphasize that uh
it would be difficult to make an
assessment based on just
one uh video or one speech
and so i am referring to a pattern over
time
over decades in fact of um numerous
interviews
and numerous uh patterns of speech that
have changed
and you're absolutely right in that um
his
wandering off uh from
losing his way is a red flag
um a very concerning sign in uh
relation to the his dramatically
shrinking vocabulary
and just about any speech that you can
hear nowadays
um notes his veering off topic
his unable his inability to to stay on
topic his repetition of stories
uh his increasing repetition over time
and
and also something that we call loose
associations and that
he jumps from one topic to another that
are
not essentially related to one another
but but in his mind
uh in his own logic they are related and
so
uh so all of those things are concerning
and
um are happening in the presence of
other symptoms such as his increasing
tendency to to um
espouse conspiracy theories to
uh to detach himself from reality
to show um greater signs of
impatience impulsivity um
poor decision making and inability to
take in
information that is important inability
to consider consequences before making
uh very momentous decisions
and all of the things that we actually
formally assessed
uh in a mental capacity evaluation uh i
can tell you a bit more about that if
you'd like
yeah well so i mean i think maybe this
is a good time to compare and contrast
you mentioned joe biden
and the the some some people immediately
around donald trump including his son
have been over the last three to four
weeks kind of pushing this idea of joe
biden has dementia
and you've already alluded to this a
little bit and saying that what you see
with joe biden is different
to me as a layperson if i see joe
biden's debate with paul ryan in 2012
and compare it to the way that he's
conducting interviews now
there is a difference i can't say there
is not a difference and and it seems
like sort of a slow down is the very
informal way that i would describe it as
a guy who's now 78 years old rather than
70 when he was debating paul ryan
but from your perspective which is a
trained eye
can you talk a little bit about what's
different about those details and what
you see with joe biden versus donald
trump
well first of all i uh would
refrain from making any specific
comments because
i have not observed mr biden enough
um also i
don't generally comment on public
figures unless they pose
a danger to society and a danger to the
public's well-being
which is my threshold for commenting on
public figures
and so what i will say is that there
have been
uh not really glaring signs that would
make me concerned about any catastrophic
danger to the public
i uh i do notice the things that other
people have remarked about the changes
over time
and also the the different
gaffes that many people have remarked on
which for the most part i will ha uh i
will in general just say
that they are uh that they would
uh fall under a more superficial
category
than the ones that we see with donald
trump which are
truly serious impairments that would
concern us
about catastrophic danger to
the nation's well-being if not the world
how can we tell the difference and and
maybe i mean
i'm curious what would make it rise or
not
rise to that threshold of danger that
you talk about
so um i told you about the
violence-proneness and
uh the the the apparent mental
incapacity that
mr trump has exhibited um
mainly what we'd be concerned about in
terms of public safety
are dangerousness and unfitness
and uh with regard to dangerousness it
would be
um the president's uh
apparent violent violence proneness that
that he has already shown
and that he has actually demonstrated
throughout this presidency and actually
placed our nation in danger multiple
times
um uh i mean there there
could be a whole list he has brought us
to the brink of war
numerous times he has taunted
other powers he has severed um
or weakened our uh our relationships
with allies
he has destabilized
our position geopolitically
these are the kinds of things that would
be particularly dangerous
and in terms of unfitness we actually
did do
a mental capacity evaluation on the
president when the correct information
became available
now this is uh the special counsel
robert mueller's report which contained
multiple reports from close associates
and
and co-workers who had direct
interactions with the president
and if the report was not uh enough to
indict a president it was certainly
enough
to assess mental capacity that is
the capacity to fulfill the duties of
his office
now without the basic medical uh the
mental capacity
there's no chance that he could be
mentally fit that he could be fit for
duty
uh and he in fact failed every criterion
uh the criterion include the the ability
to take in
information and facts uh advice from his
advisors is necessary to the situation
the ability to uh to be flexible and
manipulate the information he receives
not be bound to uh fixed ideas or
conspiracy theories
to be able to make decisions that are
sound
reality based and rational
that consider consequences and are not
done impulsively and that he goes back
and forth after making this
decision these are all
factors we consider in a mental capacity
evaluation so that
he failed definitively and for that we
do not need a personal interview
although we did invite him for an
interview in case
he considered himself fit and would like
to give us information that might
overturn our findings but this was uh
definitive and it was done by
independent top mental health experts uh
a panel of them
and it was done for uh in service of the
public
in order to inform the public of what it
was facing
um now these are the kinds of
information we look for
when when uh we suspect a person would
be dangerous
in the president's position and these
are not the kinds of information we
found
in mr biden but we have certainly
recommended that any
uh candidate uh for the presidency or
vice presidency
submit themselves to an independent
expert panel who can do a fitness for
duty exam
uh it is fairly um it is fairly rapid
it's not a diagnostic exam it doesn't
involve
a review of one's entire medical history
or medical records
it simply assesses whether or not the
person is ready for duty
and uh so we definitely do recommend
this of mr biden himself
so that was going to be the last thing i
was going to ask and you've sort of you
sort of addressed it which is
certainly if we were to require
or recommend or request that
anybody who might be president be
screened
it seems very clear that the montreal
cognitive assessment
falls dramatically short of counting as
as anything definitive as you've pointed
out
uh and and would would the furthest that
you could go
be a full neuropsychiatric evaluation
with a full review of medical files like
would that be the complete opposite end
and you're recommending something that
is
that is not quite so so involved
uh yes um it would allow for
a diagnosis which would also be able to
give a prognosis
in terms of his trajectory over time and
and also enable us to treat him for any
conditions that
would be of uh imminent danger to his
own personal health which would then by
extension
affect his fitness for duty so yes that
is something that we would
recommend but above all he needs
an examination by an independent panel
not tied by his uh by
under uh employment by the white house
or uh not politically um
involved in terms of their potential
promotion and so on
and uh this is also where uh the
american psychiatric association
needs to rescind its uh
political compromise which has gone only
in one direction
only in the direction of not commenting
on a public figure
regardless of need when there are
specifically
areas where we ought to comment in order
to
improve the public health and to do our
professional
responsibility to society which is
absolutely
one of our duties as psychiatrists and
mental health professionals
in addition to seeing patients and
treating
uh individuals we've been speaking with
dr
bandy x lee who is a yale university
forensic psychiatrist
i so appreciate your time and and thank
you so much for sharing your thoughts
with our audience
thank you so much for having me